this from the post-millennial says a
biological male inmate imprisoned for
life for strangling a cellmate to death
in 2004 and previously identified as a
transgender woman is now demanding to be
treated like a baby by prison staff and
wants to be given diapers and baby food
according to the daily record 36 year
old convicted killer sophie eastwood
formerly known as daniel was sentenced
to prison for life back in 2004 after
strangling cellmate paul algy with
shoelaces
um eastwood has been jailed at dumfries
young offenders institution at 18 for
dangerous driving and then strangled and
killed someone now he's in jail for life
uh in 2016 eastwood then claimed to be a
woman
originally he said he was a a gay man
and then he said well okay it turns out
i'm actually a woman and this was in a
psychologist session in prison
and
so i guess the psychologist so we've got
a guy who's in prison
for for murdering somebody and uh he
says oh i'm actually a woman and then
the the highly trained psychologist says
oh i guess you are
you could you couldn't possibly be wrong
about who you are but you certainly
couldn't tell any lies you're just a
convicted murderer is all
and so eastwood has been jailed in a
women's prison since 2018 and takes a
testosterone blocking drug
again follow the follow the trajectory
there it makes a lot of sense right
you've got a convicted murderer
obviously a dangerous person
says i'm a woman
and then immediately it's well you you
couldn't possibly be wrong you couldn't
be deluded
you couldn't be lying and why not just
put you to women's prison
it's not like you've demonstrated
yourself to be a violent dangerous
person
and so they got he got exactly what he
wants every step of the way of course
and
now he identifies
rather than a woman more specifically he
identifies as a baby
and demands diapers and baby food from
the prison staff
i guess there's a question about
whether he identifies as a
as a female baby i'm not exactly sure
but he he identifies as a baby and he's
being given
that's how he's being treated by prison
staff
there is there's there's no end to it
once you
remove yourself from reality and you
start to if you you you declare that we
have to affirm someone's alleged
self-perception
uh no matter how far that self
perception is from reality of course
there's no end to it
i mean why not just release him from
prison i guess if he's a baby then uh he
like who puts babies in prison this is a
this is a human rights violation
i mean can you imagine but he identifies
as a he identifies us
as a one-year-old
what kind of backwards
society would put a one-year-old in
prison for god's sake
so just release him from releasing from
prison entirely why not
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated